معنى الان سعيده لجابر من الرياض للوقوف
عند هذه الزياره زياره الرئيس الصيني اهلا
بك سعيد نتوقف معك عند اجنده هذه الزياره
في اليوم الثاني
لزياره الرئيس الصيني الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
[موسيقى]
في قصر اليمامه بالعاصمه السعوديه الرياض
راح يكون هناك همم العديد من البرامج
اللقاءات والالاتفاقيات التي خلال يوميا
الزياره لا شكل اهم لقاء العاهل السعودي
همم الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز ال سعود
وكذلك ولي العهد رئيس مجلس الوزراء الامير
محمد بن سلمان بن عبد العزيز السعوديه
والصين مفتاح الشرق الاوسط وعملاق
الاقتصاد العالمي هذا ما يمكن ان يتم
تفسيره خلال اللقاء القائم اليوم في
العاصمه الرياض والذي يتمثل في زياره يقوم
بها الرئيس الصيني هذه الزياره الهامه
التي تتعقد او يعقدها الرئيس الصيني منذ
جاء احد كتب
لا تكاد ان تذكر يجب القول يوم ان العالم
كريمته ينظر الى الرياض
له عده مسببات اهمها اشارات التموضع
العالمي الجديده فلسطين التي تعتبر قطبا
اقتصاديا اليوم لا يمكن الاستغناء عنه
علميا تبحث عن منفذ تضمن من خلاله تنميه
اقتصاديتها العالم السعوديه نعيد تتحدث عن
اجنده الزياره لرئيس الصيني وجرى الحديث
عن
بقيه
عقد ثلاث قمم سعوديه صينيه خليجيه صينيه
وعربيه صينيه حدثنا عن كل ذلك من فضلك
صحيح هناك هذه الزياره يعقد على هامشها
القمه السعوديه الصينيه من المرتقب عند
توقع السعوديه والصين ايضا اكثر من 20
اتفاقيه اوليه بقيمه تتجاوز 110 مليار
ريال وتسعه المملكه الى جانب ذلك بناء
شراكه استراتيجيه تدعم التجاره والاستثمار
مع الجانب الصيني همم هناك ايضا قمم اخرى
همم قمه الرياضه العربيه الصينيه للتعاون
والتنميه وايضا قمه رياض الخليجيه الصينيه
للتعاون والتنميه راح يكون هناك ايضا
مشاركه لا اكثر من 30 رئيس دوله خلال هذه
الزياره وهو همم همم مع سيكون شاهدا على
اهميه هذه الزياره حيث يجلسون على طاوله
واحده مع عملاق الاقتصاد العالمي يبدو ان
السعوديه تريد توجيه رساله للعرب من خلال
هذه الزياره مفادها ان اا قاده العرب علي
همم عليهم استقبال الرئيس الصيني وتريد ان
تقول للعرب تفضلوا وناقشه الاقتصاد
العالمي لجميع اكبر قدر ممكن من التنميه
القائمه على الاقتصاد المنفتح من ناحيه
اخرى هناك رساله للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تريد السعوديه همم تريد القول
واشنطن ايضا انها تتحالف مع اقوى حديث
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في المنطقه
والمقصود المملكه العربيه السعوديه همم
تركت صفقات سلاح ضخمه مع دول الخليج خلال
القمه همم
صينيه الخليجيه كما ذكر اخبارها وسائل
الاعلام التي قدمت صفقات السلاح المجمعه
30 مليار دولار بين جانبي بين الصين
والسعودي السعوديه اليوم لدي عقود مع
الجانبيه في مدينه نيوم همم ب 500 مليار
دولار وربما تحتل المرتبه الاولى من حيث
حجم العقود لذلك هذه الزياره لها اهميه
كبرى لا شكل لك سعيد جابر